[Music]  here's to hotel transylvania  johnny works so hard to make this extra  special  [Music]  ruined everything johnny what are you  talking about your dad never really  thought of me as part of the family  all because i'm not a monster you want  to become a monster huh  van helsing the muncification ray turns  humans into monsters and monsters  into humans but is this safe though  great question  that's weird nothing happened  [Music]  the nightmare it's over i'm human again  [Music]  no no it can't be you're a human and  i'm a monster it's like freaky friday  but on a tuesday though  what's going on  my fur  what's up fellas frank oh i'm falling  [Applause]  [Music]  bye